تواجه روسيا انتقادات داخليا بعد مقتل 63
من جنودها في اوكرانيا بضربه اوكرانيا لم
يسبق ان ابلغ الجيش الروسي الذي قليلا ما
يتحدث عن عدد القتلى والجرح في صفوفه عن
تكبد مثل هذه الخسائر الفادحه في هجوم
واحد منذوبه ايه تداخله العسكري شهر شباط
فبراير الماضي ما اثار انتقادات للقياده
العسكريه الروسيه نتوقف مشاهدينا الكرام
عند هذه التطورات في فقره وقفه مع الحدث
مع الزميل عبد الله العالي عبد الله اهلا
بك كما ذكرت من النادر ان يعترف الروس
بخسائرهم في حرب اوكرانيا لماذا اقروا
بهذا العدد من القتل هذه المره
مكرهون اخر كلام بطل كما يقول المثل يعني
انه لم يكن امامهم اي خيار اخر لان همم
لان الهجوم الذي الصاروخيه الذي شناه
الجيش الاوكراني على المبنى الذي كان يوجد
فيه هؤلاء المجند دون الروس كان احدث
انفجار من
وكان همم امام اعين همم لانفصاليين همم
الموجودين في اقليم الدسك
وكان ايضا امام عيون السكان المدنيين وكان
يشاهد وايضا اعداد اخرون من الجيش الروسي
وبالتالي لم يكن بالامكان ابدا التكتم او
التستر عليه بل ان اي محاوله من ذلك نوع
كانت تعصف بما تبقى من مصداقيه الجيش
الروسي همم لدى همم مختلف الاطراف
وبالتالي تمنت القياده الرئيس الروسيه
خياره الاعلام ولكنها مع ذلك اعلنت عن رقم
يبدون الكثير من المراقبين بانه رقم مقلد
او اقل من الواقع لانها قالت لان الهجوم
لم يحدث الا ثلاثا و60 قتيلا فحسد همم
والواقع ان الروس يدركون بان هذا الاعلان
ستكون له تداعيات داخل روسيا اذا انه همم
ادى الى بروث انتقادات لعدم كفاءه القياده
العسكريه الروسيه الحرب في اوكرانيا وعدم
قدرتها على حمايتها هؤلاء المجندين الذين
نشروا قبل وقت قصير في هذه المنطقه من
اوكرانيا ولكنها مع ذلك تامل ان يؤدي همم
هذا الاعلان الى احداث وثبه وطنيه اي ان
يشعر الروس بانهم مهددون وبان الاسلحه
التي يقتلنا بها هي اسلحه امريكيه
وبالتالي يعزز السرديه الروسيه القائله
بان موسكو لا تواجهه في اوكرانيا همم
مقاتلين او جيشا او معداتنا واسلحه
واقرانيه وانما ما تواجه حربا بالوكاله مع
الغرب ومع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه على
امل ان يحدث ذلك صدمه ايجابيه في الجمهور
الروسي تجعله اكثر تقبلا
لتقديم تضحيات همم ترى موسكو من شانها
وحدها اا ان تجعلها تكسب في نهايه المطاف
هذه الحرب
ايهما اقرب للتصديق في حرب الارقام هذه
روايه موسكو ام روايه كاف
لماذا روايتك تقول بان هذا الهجوم ادى الى
مسقطي الى سقوط اكثر من 40 مئه قتيل
والواقع ان هنالك مصادر محليه من اقليم
الدوسريسك وردت في وكاله الانباء وهي
مصادر همم بالاساس من همم معسكر
الانفصاليين الموالي لروسيا في اقليم
الدراسه والتي تقدر عدد
القتلى ب 100
والواقع ايضا ان هذه المصادر اوضح احد ان
الهجوم استهدف هذا المبنى وان المبنى تم
تدميره بالكامل وان الشيء الذي ادى الى
كونه الانفجار كان ضخما انه كان توجد
عسكريه
خائر ذخائر عسكريه في نفس المبنى وانها
انفجرت في الوقت ذاتي مما ادى الى تضعه في
عدد الخسائر الماديه والبشريه فيه علما
باننا نعرف ايضا من مصادر اعلاميه روسي
بان هذا المبنى كان يوجد فيه 600
600 شخص قبل الانفجار حسب التقديرات وسائل
الاعلام الروسيه وبالتالي اذا ما كان مبنى
يوجد فيه 600 عسكريا او مجلد وقد امر
بالكامل وقد احدث ضرب الصواريخ له هجوما
لكميات من الذخيره كانت موجوده
فبالتالي تبدو الروايه الاوكرانيه اقربائي
للتصديق واقرب الى المستقيه همم من
الروايه الروسيه فيما يتعلق بعد عده
القتلى
هل هناك تغير جوهري في التوازنات
الميدانيه الان ما نعرفه ان الجبهه حتى
الان بالمجمل تعتبر جبهه عسكريه ثابته
ومستقره ولكن لا نعرف بان الحركيه العامه
للحرب تصب في مصلحه اوكرانيا في الاشهر
الاخيره لان روسيا منيت في الاشهر الاخيره
ميدانيه مذله مهينه بالنسبه للجيش الروسي
وهي هزائم جعلت الجيش الاوكرانيه حسب
روايته يستعيد 40% من الاراضي التي
احتلتها روسيا منذ بدايه الحرب في فبراير
شباط الماضي لكن نعرف ايضا انه هنالك وهذا
ربما هو الذي يجعل الاعلان عن الرقم
الحقيقي او معرفه الرقم الحقيقي بالنسبه
لضحايا الهجوم الاخير امر متعذر او غير
ممكن الا بعد عقدنا وعقود حينما
ينكب المؤرخون العسكريون على الشهادات
وعلى الوثائق
لان اي اعلان من هذا الشان من شانه من
شانه ان يغير الديناميكيه الحرب لانه اذا
ما اتضح ان الاوكرانيين لم يعد بهم لم
استنزفوا او يستنفذوا كل قوام فانه لم يعد
بامكانهم القيام بهجوم مضاد في المستقبل
واذا ما تاكد ان روسيا منيه بخسائر كبيره
فان ذلك سيجعل قدره على مقاومه اي هجوم
اوكرانيين همم معكس جديد امرا مستبعدا همم
او ضعيف الاحتمال وعليه فان الكل ينتظر
الان همم نهايه فصل الشتاء وبدايه فصل همم
الربيع المقبل لانه يتوقع ان تبدا ان ذلك
هجمات عسكريه في هذا الاتجاه
وهناك استعدادات لهذا الشان لان
الاوروبيين تحديدا يستعدون لعقد مؤتمر مع
اوكرانيا على مستوى القمه في الشهر المقبل
حشد الدعم الع والمادي الذي مثانه ان يمكن
اوكرانيا من مقاومه اي هجوم واسع نطاق قد
تشونه القوه الروسيه في الاسابيع والاشهر
المقبله شكرا جزيلا لك عبد الله العلي على
كل هذه التفاصيل المتعلقه بالملف
الاوكراني